when I'm up in the plane I I think about
the history of what's gone on on the
ground in the snowpack every once in a
while you get to look out the windows
and you're looking at the most
spectacular mountains in the world
it's absolutely incredible
the airborne snow Observatory is a pair
of instruments on an aircraft they look
out the bottom and they measure the snow
depth and the snow reflectivity and the
combination of that information gives us
what we need to know to understand the
timing and the magnitude of snowmelt
runoff which is key to the water
resources in the western US we're now in
the fourth year of drought it's
unbelievably extreme compared to
anything we have on record we're seeing
where we would normally have you know
five six ten feet of snow bare ground
and that's where the ASO project is so
important
the plane will take off and it'll get up
to high enough altitude that we can
cover mountain basins by flying back and
forth while we're up there we turn on
the instruments and we make the
measurements of the snow topography and
the snow reflectivity or how much
sunlight is being absorbed by the by the
surface after a few hours of flying
these large mountain basins plane lands
and we pull the data off of the plane
take them over to a very heavy computing
system and start crunching through those
data down to the two main products of
snow water equivalent and snow
reflectivity now we're to the point
where from the time the plane lands
until we have the products that the
water managers need and the snow
hydrologists need it's less than 24
hours and that makes it meaningful
information it means that they can take
action on that information right away
water managers in these mountains always
need to know how much snow pack there is
how quickly it's coming out how much
total there's going to be they watch
this information they use it in their
models they use it in their
decision-making with respect to
allocation of water the conventional
techniques for measuring the Sierra
snowpack have historically been point
measurements those are fairly sparse
even though we think we've got quite a
few of them once of measurement spot is
0 then you're basically fine blind you
don't have that data that you need to
manage sort of that final amount of
inflow that's coming into your reservoir
the ASO program provides that complete
picture of the watershed snowpack so
that even while these point measurement
locations are bare we're still getting
data from the airborne observatory it's
amazing how quickly water managers have
suddenly recognized like wow this is
data that I can really use
we have put together partnerships with
the city of San Francisco with their
hetch hetchy reservoir operation turlock
irrigation district Modesto Irrigation
District all of these entities have have
started making use of the data to know
that we're taking care of the most
critical resource for all of those
people it's a good feeling to be able to
bring the technology for that purpose